hello and welcome to this video oh I got
the number wrong and it's actually yeah
okay so 1.e4 against just add magic and
I'm adding magic by trading on d5 let's
see what he's up to
so we got an IQ p position and you know
black is going for and more active set
up knight c6 can you actually take on
default I just looked like I can take a
seven but my Bishop is also hanging hmm
maybe yeah he could have taken okay so
this is an interesting line look here
what's going on this okay d5
I cannot believe 94-94 queen is seven
that working for luck I would be
extremely strange but maybe maybe twenty
four ninety seven ninety two now can I
believe it I just developed the bishop
okay
it just plays at him
so yeah you become yeah I I cannot take
here or I can take actually I mean my
queen is covering this so and then I
have two minor pieces for you can corner
what a weird weird development that's
really really yeah unusual I came Knight
to Eve form wants to activate the rook
if possible I try to develop quickly and
get the bishops into good positions if
he takes context Queen f6 Bishop e3
there should be three Quincy 354 resigns
so I'm trying to get the bishop on to d4
I would be a fantastic square for the
piece maybe he intends to trade Queen
say with Queen g6 but you know
yeah we can't pong against two minor
pieces is oftentimes actually quite good
for the rook but this is not one of
those cases here the position I think
with good technical play why should win
let's see if I can manage some of this
technical play the rooks have no school
no space no no scope and the bishop on
c6 alone is fantastic really so I'm
going to try to increase the pressure
here with a 5 and c5 yeah I think just
going to cover it like that
yeah after c5 it's going to be difficult
as he would have to almost have to take
yeah I should be too much yeah there is
an interesting tribe but I mean I can
take so after the capture he's going to
play probably rookie former do I have
something better now probably not and
that's it's fine
I think it's fine to take and then I
wanted to go look see one only now oh
it's no problem ever see rupee for but I
can actually probably just take after
take and Bishop f4
do this and take a five
I mean if you have ever watched one of
my videos or more than one you know that
I have this huge fan of the bishop pair
and this is fantastic
you know I think this just didn't work
that's six but maybe the engine proves
otherwise this looks fairly normal when
black should play Bishop d6 96 okay-okay
96 might work but I'm unsure about
Bishop g4 interesting so d5 and Knight
a5 works oh that's interesting and it's
it once you see it and it's kind of
obvious that it works but I didn't see
it at all during the game so this one
hmm
Bishop if I take here I'll take here
right immediately I'm not trading only 7
yeah it's nothing special
yeah so that is actually justifying we
should reform but 94 should do it I take
take and Bishop g5 interesting
Wow
I have to understand first what this
does when I'm still threatening to take
a selfie step so if he retreats this I'm
going to take and then this yeah I mean
it looks great yeah but who's playing
like this if he takes it I'm still
threatening this and this and to take
out it's it's bad so far for him yeah so
it's that bad
and it's actually not great this this
and now Quincy aid would have been a
cold shower Wow Wow I cannot take
because here a queen is lost at least
maybe it's got something better
Wow yeah that's what you should have
done and it looks really really
dangerous
rookie form okay
yeah just be winning from black
basically okay so it didn't work what he
did but not you
yeah but but not due to my move okay
yeah I should be fine yeah I think I'm
fine queen a3 looks good
Quinn GeForce well I did take take and
cunha sixes probably I was just helping
me a but should be three I think as good
as the bishop is ideal on deform and
after the Queen trade I think it's a
technical Owen you're not happy about be
successful black but you cannot cover
the pawn like rook b8 there is Bishop f4
and you have no other meal and this is
just like absolutely terrible
so advanced this just want to check it
there was I missed something but it
looks very convincing yeah and resigns
this is nothing you can do it cannot
even look it's no check or attack or
whatever here this is just taken okay
guys thanks for watching